[Music]
Howard that's the White House Howard
hunt Howard the president asked for a
real son of a to handle this
Pentagon leak what do you need I want
you to meet Gordon Liddy toughest guy I
know to hold his hand in the flame of
the candle I do not Bend and I do not
break what's the trick there's a one
it's third degree burns every time
please stop
we now work for the committee to reelect
the president
your new mission is to make sure he wins
this election will intercept
confidential information of the radical
left
what's the plan we're going to hit the
DNC at the Watergate Howard that is the
stupidest thing I've ever heard
we strike tonight
these are the wrong doors what he has
the wrong tools
[Music]
this time we walk straight in the front
door
it's a double-sided deadbolt
somebody needs to clean this mess up you
want us to break in a fourth time wait
what do you mean a fourth time
nothing spy talk
how does it work there's a chance I'd be
going to prison
wait what
I really hope you understand the scope
and scale of this thing you tell those
spineless two-faced politicians loyalty
is a two-way street
[Applause]
did you just use the fun and family
outing to cover up some spy fish
we're not a bunch of bulls why are you
shredding money with Patriots acting in
the country's best interests
what about the best interest of your
family
[Music]
they are trying to break us
president is a good man
between you and me I worry about some of
the people with whom he surrounds
himself
[Music]
plumbers who fix leaks